hi everyone it's Jerry I have a nice
game to share with you from the 2007
linars tournament
on the white end of vishyanand and he's
playing against Magnus Carlson
okay on board
Ray Lopez
and in this one we have a closed really
some security Now for the e-pawn
Bishop is kicked back
secures E5 this frees up the knight from
its defensive role
so nearby he's ready to hunt the bishop
white says not so fast I have a square
if you go in for that
and I'm also prepping a D4 advance
after Castle's a little bit more prep
work by white
B4 playing D4 commonplace here H3
this cuts out the pin on the Knight
more long-term white has that flight
Square
if white doesn't play in this way if he
doesn't preface D4 with H3
and this pin on the Knight is irritating
Black's now threatening to knock out
essentially two Defenders
of D4
one of the benefits in playing D4 one of
the benefits of having this Pawn on D4
is staying flexible keeping black
guessing am I going to take am I going
to push am I going to sit there is value
in that and it becomes much more
difficult for white to maintain that
flexibility if this pin is allowed
so that's why it is first H3
Black Goes hunting for the bishop is
this really the primary idea probably
not no guarantee you're getting that
exchange sure enough Bishop C2
what was the primary idea behind this
move
really a clearance
here comes the C pun it's now a
contributor for Center Square
in comes D4
and Knight D7 noted as the carries
variation
black secures E5
and
clears the way
for the F Pawn to contribute
in this game it's D5 straight away so
space grab by Anand
how do we play Within this structure
well first the Knight gets out of The
Bishop's way
and is keying in on the C4 Square
Knight B to D2
and now G6 so black has a flight Square
black is also maybe now
in some cases supporting F5
I do know that it's not a good idea for
black to rush right in with this Pawn
break in this position
and the reason for that is because a
white knight will end up on an excellent
Square
E4
so this is how it would play out if you
play F5 straight away
this would be in excellent position for
white
so in this game it's G6
and now B4
now to my surprise
the top
suggestion by the engine
is to feed Kettle the Knight
so in the game
we have the exchange of C pawns our
first exchange of anything and then the
Knight goes forward but I dug deeper I
was just way too curious to know why
this night why this is considered the
best reply
here's the thing if you play Knight B7
you have to see pretty deep you have to
know that the only way this Knight gets
back into activity
is to get to the F7 Square
there is no guarantee that the Knight
can find activity on the queen side if
you're going to B7 in this position
there's no guarantee you could
successfully undermine the B4 point
so this Pawn on V4
will be maintained it can be maintained
and for as long as it's maintained it
dominates the Knight where else could
the night go
to d8 but from d8 it's the same story
you're boxed out by a knight
therefore the Knight has to go to d8 the
F Pawn has to move so finally the Knight
has at least a semi-active square on F7
controlling some King side squares it
controls a whole
on H6 and maybe even in some cases from
f the F7 point
that Knight could take up a post on E5
if white is trying to break on the king
side with F4 there's really a lot to
take in before making this committal
decision Knight B7
okay in this game the exchange of C
Pawns
the Knight now goes into C4 going with
the fiend keto in this position is less
attractive
this is a big maneuver
to get these moves in and it's
much more difficult to get those Moves
In
if
the position is more opened you have
you'll have a better chance of success
to get that maneuver in in a closed
environment
all right in this game it is Knight a to
C4
pair of knights come off
Bishop B3
really can't allow this Exchange
that pawn is probably going to be won
very soon if you allow that
so for instance let's just say something
like this
this one's going to be targeted really
soon some Rook up and over looks
attractive
so he simply backs off additionally
trying to support the Knight with Queen
C7 is not good
because you would end up
in
a pin
so the Knight simply retreats
Queen Bishops are developed
get to the open file there go a pair of
knights
and now white is there first getting to
the only opened file
Bishop D7
Rook C1 and now how do you stop white
from entering
black plays the best move it's not fun
to play in this way
but it is best
and apparently still a holdable position
for black
yep the Knight is officially cornered to
prevent
Queen C7
we continue
Queen D2
Queen B8
and now Bishop G5 so this is getting
into middle game plan how do you try and
make progress in this position well
white sees it as I need to get some dark
Square Bishop Exchange in there without
the dark Square Bishop around
these squares are a little bit more
sensitive in Black's Camp maybe I can
take advantage of that
um
what do you do from here the dark Square
Bishop exchange cannot be avoided
we have the bishop capture I thought to
myself is it possible black can maybe
play F6 and prevent The Exchange the
answer to that is no
Can you spot why F6 is no good
feel free to pause the video
okay there would be an excellent tactic
here for white
if F6
and the tactic is Knight takes E5
so as soon as that F pawn moves this
bishop size widened there are Now tricks
let's have a look at the different
captures if you take first with the
d-pawn
that hurts discovered check the bishop
is gonna fall
winning for white
you take with this okay simple enough we
take the bishop we're up a pawn
and lastly if you take here that hurts
as well we get the material back
and we're going to be up the exchange
soon enough
so F6 is no good the dark Square Bishop
will happen
Bishop takes Bishop
and now how to recapture
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video
how would you recapture here
okay in the game it's Knight takes
Bishop they're both pretty close in
evaluation
these captures but you know the computer
does like a little bit more Knight takes
on G5
why is that
we're gonna see soon enough we're gonna
revisit this position but first let's
get some more moves in
Rook C8 is played
and from here
white ducks The Rook exchange and is
clearly ready to advance
with F4
in the game we now continue with H6 this
is considered
a losing move
Can you spot why
feel free to pause the video
okay the best move
move played in the game 96.
this was one of the points behind
recapturing on G5 with the Knight
white has in mind this
x-rayed intersection Square E6
this guy can easily become a star piece
because of this Knight diving in to this
Square
now let me go back to this position
right here and point out what is
considered
the best continuation
best is King G7
and then after F4
H6 in this position this is not this is
considered still a move actually but
it's not as effective as when it was
played in the game
this is considered the best reply and
from here F6 this is how the computer
wants to play still
apparently in a level position
Now what is
what are many of the points behind this
particular recapture this is how I view
it
if you're recapturing with the queen
you're improving just
the queen
but by capturing with the Knight
you are improving the night
in a way you are taking a step towards
improving The Rook
he has this idea to advance now the F
Pawn with the Knight no longer on F3
he wants to do something on the f file
and in a way you are also helping to
improve as odd as this may seem you're
helping to maybe improve the light
Square Bishop because of this Square
this jump on E6 this guy is not really a
contributor in this position but with
the Knight on G5 he makes it a
contributor
so in a way I know it's a simplified way
to view it but by recapturing on G5 with
the knight in a way these three pieces
are helped
okay we continue in this game Rook C8
Rook exchange is avoided
H6 meant with or met with Knight E6 the
computer at this point
instead of H6 it says go in for Queen A7
pin this Pawn at least for a second and
then try to get the Queens off
well basically this is forcing some end
game situation where black is going to
be down upon
computer knows it's
getting dangerous here on the king's
side and we know who's not going to be
around anytime soon to help defend the
king side that is this cornered Knight
okay
black goes with H6 though misses this
big move Knight E6 so
what do you do from here in the game
it's King H7 but question is of course
what happens if the Knight is captured
or recapturing or on the bishop
and then we can also next take the pawn
this is an enormous position
there's the threat to advance with
discover check
for instance let's say the queen goes
here
we have this
followed by this taking advantage of the
PIN
Etc mate right around the corner
some other testing Try
in this position instead of Queen A7
let's say Knight B6
we could still go with this discovered
check the Knight can clog up this file
here but after this check in F4 this is
also a winning continuation for white
there's no fear of a fancy discovered
attack against the queen she could
always react with check this Rook will
be brought to life soon enough along the
f-file
okay
the Knight is not captured in this
position the Knight is not captured in
this game
well
he's not captured by a pawn
in this game it's King H7
in comes F4
Queen A7 check
King H2
Bishop to E8 so even in this position
taking with the Knight is no good
because look at this
F5
it's well known to
two connected past pawns on the sixth
rank you know they're frequently more
valuable than a rook so
this guy is non-existent he might as
well just be here
okay
that would be way too strong I just
don't even know
how you would even stop this idea to
Simply push the F Pawn so
the Knight is still poison
from here Bishop E8
F5
and G takes F5 is tried what else can
you do here as black if you try G5
you're asking for this sacrifice
followed up with
F6 this doesn't even allow the queen
to do anything on the seventh rank
doesn't allow black an opportunity to
play F6 himself and nearby we have chop
and then mate
this is no defense Rook F5 would be
there and that's just hitting that much
harder
okay no G5 in the game G takes f
e takes f
and now simply F6
from here rookie one I guess in a way
keeping a close eye in any advance by
the pawn as it turns out in this game
short-lived on E1
Knight C7
there's now a pin on the C file
Bishop D7 unpins the Knight
Rook C3
E4 Rook G3
yeah it's getting pretty dangerous here
Rook G6 Queen takes H6 look at all these
pieces they're really just out of bound
out of bounds over committed
what do you do in this game Knight takes
Knight
white does not take towards the center
he extends the scope of the B3 Bishop
D takes on E6
this is now also a Target
from here Bishop E7 excuse me Bishop B8
E7 is now played and do you see the
threat
The Bishop's eyes are now completely
opened to G8 that's red is check
and then after the King goes to h8
checkmate
also the simple threat to take the pawn
black cannot defend these two moves
he defends the mate threat The Rook is
now there but there goes the d-pawn and
there goes uh this game black now
resigns what do you do lights now up a
pawn and the attack continues there's no
way
to even stop the follow-up move Queen
takes F6
with Rook G7 Queen G7 ideas
no solution here for black if we have a
look at one test line for instance Rook
E8
queen of six Queen takes Pawn could be
met with Bishop G8 check you have to
take with the Rook there goes the queen
there goes the game
but after Queen takes D6 in this one it
goes no further black simply resigns
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign